Kylie Jenner get at me
do I even need to say it here folks like
I'm pretty sure Kylie Jenner invented
the body check
this breakfast looks delicious looks
like we've got some yogurt for protein
and fat plus granola and berries for our
fiber now I don't know what kind of
yogurt that is but I always do recommend
full fat Greek yogurt if you're not
intolerant to Dairy for the best
nutrition bang for your buck Greek
yogurt has 15 grams of protein per three
quarters of a cup less calcium and other
essential nutrients and while we used to
demonize saturated fat quite a lot in
the nutrition world we now know that
dairy fat specifically has a lot of
potential Health Benefits full fat
fermented dairy tends to be associated
with lower risk of heart disease obesity
and insulin resistance or diabetes it's
also way more delicious and satiating
than fat free because of that fat so
it's really a win-win all around in my
books
coconut water is a delicious way to get
in your hydration plus some electrolytes
like magnesium and potassium but just
keep in mind that water just plain old
H2O is a perfectly fine source of
hydration for most folks
this looks delicious we've got fiber in
the greens and some fat in the dressing
and almonds but I would say for a meal
this is leaving a lot to be desired it's
pretty low carb and virtually protein
free so I would love to see that bumped
up by adding in some chicken or some
tofu and maybe some pita on the side
oh
so much to unpack here so little time
folks lemon water is flavored water with
a little vitamin C it doesn't detox you
it doesn't cause weight loss or reduced
bloating and it definitely doesn't
alkalinize your blood as for chlorophyll
I think most of the tick tock hype was
based on a few small studies which
suggested that it can clear up your skin
and help reduce the signs of aging but
all of these studies looked at
chlorophyll as a topical skin treatment
not something that you ingest in your
water if you want chlorophyll folks just
like eat a salad
okay this looks like a beautiful meal
but I would say that most of us would
need a lot more carbs and more chicken
in that scoop of pasta to feel like we
had a satisfying meal this would
definitely not be enough for me
especially in the context of this day of
eating which I would say was pretty
light so if you're watching Tick Tock
creators or celebrities wedding a days
like Kylie and thinking wow I shouldn't
have carbs at lunch or whoa I shouldn't
have more than a small scoop of pasta at
dinner know that this dietitian thinks
that most of us including Kylie probably
should hope that review was helpful fall
for a balanced nutrition advice